The creators of the movie Jurassic Park used
sounds from a baby elephant, alligator, and
tiger combined to bring the dinosaur roar
to life.
Audiences loved it, but scientists… yeah…
Not so much.
terror lizards
Dinosaurs have been gone for 65 million years,
so, no human has ever heard one roar.
Never.
In the movies dinosaurs had sustained echoing
howls, but in real life?
Nah, bro.
A paper from 2009's Historical Biology attempted
to reveal exactly what some of these animals
may have sounded like, and lemme tell you,
T-Rex prolly didn't roar… instead the king
of the dinosaurs may have… said, "hisssssss."
Or maybe nothing at all.
First, there is no fossilized evidence of
dinosaur voice boxes; voice boxes are made
of flesh so they don't fossilize, and thus
we'll probably never know without a shadow
of a doubt what these animals really sounded
like.
But paleontologist Phil Senter researched
the vocalizations of living dinosaurian relatives
to try and make an educated guess.
66 million years ago, at the end of the Mesozoic
era, most dinosaurs went extinct in the K/T
Extinction event.
95 percent of the birds we have today, according
to their DNA, evolved from any small dinosaurs
not killed by the K/T event.
10 million years after that, the first shared
ancestor of all living modern crocodiles evolved,
and they've remained relatively unchanged
ever since.
So by looking at birds and crocodiles, scientists
figure, we might find some hint at what dinosaurs
sounded like.
To roar, animals have to have a voice box,
and in the case of crocs and birds they come
in different types.
Crocs use a larynx the same kind of organ
as you and me.
Birds use a little different organ called
a syrinx which generates birdsong.
Dr. Julia Clarke of the University of Texas
at Austin, told me in an email, "[the syrinx]
had no precursor organ," it evolved with birds;
AFTER dinosaur extinction, and from fossil
evidence we know the larynx did the same.
So because birds and crocs AND their voice
boxes evolved after the mass extinction of
dinosaurs, researchers posit their commonly
shared ancestor dinosaur, probably couldn't
vocalize at all.
Essentially, we KNOW dinosaurs didn't roar
because they didn't evolve voice boxes until
later.
But just because they didn't roar doesn't
mean they didn't make noise.
A paper in Anatomical Record points out, many
dinosaurs had nasal cavities, mouths and connected
noses.
This connection inside the skull created resonance
chambers, which allows animals to create all
sorts of sounds even without a larynx or syrinx.
And literally on top of that, the lambeosaurus
and hadrosaurus had massive resonating crests
connected to their breathing tracks, which
researchers think could amplify those noises
even further.
We've found fossils of these crests so we
can prove it!
Some researchers blew air through them to
show they could have produced low-frequency
sounds -- just like modern crocs and some
elephants.
So even though they didn't roar, dinosaurs
could have drummed, groaned, hissed, gurgled,
clicked, rattled, chirped and chirruped, just
like their modern relatives…
Calling out that you're the best at hunting
or mating is super important in the animal
world, but calling out your portfolio of photos,
books or Kanye gifs/gifs is super important
in the INTERNET world.
What better way to do that then with your
own website, and no domain extension will
help you tell your story like a DOT COM or
DOT NET domain name.
Because you watch DNews, you can get 15% off
Domain Dot Com’s names and web hosting by
using the code DNews when you check out, AND
it helps the show -- so thanks!
If you're looking for more dinosaur stuff,
you should take a second to watch my OTHER
science show and podcast, TestTube Plus.
On TTP we dive deep into the controversy of
the earliest dino discoveries, how some dinosaurs
you know might not be real, the black market
of dinosaur fossils and how we might be able
to bring them back.
Does it bother you when hollywood makes up
dinosaur stuff?
Like, why didn't the velociraptors have feathers?
Dinosaurs had feathers.
They did.
It's fact.
… Let me know your thoughts in the comments,
and please subscribe to DNews so you get all
12 of our videos every day, all week.